hello and welcome to see I'm playing
taught calm in the birds pills with
white yeah this is not such a great line
b5 which is a bit of a nice way to put
it yeah this is the moment where you
think with black probably why on earth
did I play b5 really Wow
I will see for developing anything they
are on the queenside oh I really don't
know what to do here because it's so do
you want to go to e2 with the bishop
yeah I mean I don't want to stay on the
tool I mean like to f3 it's probably
going to play Bishop we should be form
and actually this is actually a little
bit annoying it should be fun I don't
want to take that I don't want to let
him take yeah but ultimately I know how
corrupted it that cannot be good for
black okay I just spent too much time on
this in this year I should play Bishop
before to at least set me some problems
okay I mean trading the dark squared
Bishop just like there are nice squares
there in particular on d6 okay
he's making like 1 1 or 2 more
inaccurate moves this can be extremely
painful for black tarry close already
he's got absolutely weird pieces
okay c5 only move yeah
only move I came I'm not taking this I
want to get him into this pin and into
those pins
okay Knight e4 Knight a two way both
looks fine
and now it's not threatening
he cannot develop that's what I'm trying
to say there's just not a single move
down knight c6 Knight f6 97 maybe 97
it is hanging
many Scott nights you form him and it is
an issue
hi I probably misplayed that that said
soup that's unbelievable almost after
that ridiculous position at blackhat Wow
hey five is hanging what am I doing here
I don't believe this crap in this game
that's crazy
yeah night a five simply and what then I
have no move
he's reddening hi-de-ho after that it's
just idiotic what am i when I did he and
this game is just unspeakably terrible I
mean it was a position that was so
utterly lost strategically speaking and
I'm no two points down for nothing
amazing absolutely amazing
how can you at least set some problems
here I don't really see anything and
it's the easiest thing ever to push
those pawns
that's that that's one of the worst
losses that I can remember in recent
times because I mean what
I mean okay I'm still kind of struggling
maybe maybe he's helping me a little bit
more even okay I can't take here right
when you lost some time that's crazy
yeah yeah I'm so totally pissed off and
my own play we know because like here
you're just strategically winning with
white and I'm I just played it so
terribly now you know white has a huge
space advantage the dark squares that
Harry's got all all pawns on light
squares it is a position that you just
have to win and maybe you don't have to
win against I make this cousin or
something but against any normal player
you should well you must win with white
no matter what and that was so ugly yeah
so before you know I saw before c5 but I
just couldn't believe it at the end you
really think that black is can is alive
here
that's amazing me no development nothing
it's got an ID on b7 and still it's it's
not it's not winning or anything that's
remarkable
or at least an advantage let's say the
engine gives this solution which is kind
of it is clearly better I mean you don't
have to worry about the pawn and you
have Bishop f3 92 94 although simple
more than black assist completely boxed
in but it's remarkable that this is
really just working I mean I was really
thinking I must be I must have a huge
initiative here that overcompensates but
black is just holding you
he has got nothing developed but those
pieces they cover all the entry squares
I am and now I'm struggling could have
taken on a five already before and here
should play night b3m 495 mm and that is
that is all night eggs didn't even
consider that but it's of course
possible and I got this year there was a
totally terrible game rook d2 is a
special idiotic here because you run
into the now into the for and now I am
totally lost but which is he spoil it
somehow I mean first and foremost he
lost on time but he had blundered away
most of his advantage
at this point anyway I think okay - and
I'm probably not worth any more no and
that was badly played really
I simply assumed that after b45 there
should be something and it's a
now-or-never thing by the way he has to
play c5 now any other movie I play 94
and it's over
something like that you're never getting
out of it anymore
just totally it's totally a Boston and I
just thought okay there must be
something because well you cannot just
never develop anything and have night on
b7 and so on but it holds just holds
okay thanks for watching